minister gabriel slansberg is welcome to
deutsche welle thank you
um i would like to start with uh an
interview that uh
the president of ukraine vladimir
zelinski gave a few days ago
in which he called on the west to
essentially ban traveled by all russians
so they will feel that
their country is really at war as he
said what's your opinion of his
proposition
well i should start saying that
lithium has made this decision quite
quite early
and also not only just because of the
political reasons but also because of
the practical reasons
the thing is that
when the war started um
lithium felt um a huge influx of people
who were seeking uh
for a shelter
uh running away from prosecution beat
from from belarus which i mean started a
long time ago i mean 20 20 years yes
2020 almost two years now and also from
from russia and from moscow
um so and knowing that uh consular
capacity is limited it means that people
can issue only so many visas so
basically you have to answer yourself a
very simple question who do you issue a
visa first is it a uh
a family of uh of a you know ngo
member
who might be persecuted whose
father
or mother is being persecuted
or some tourist you know who wishes to
spend a few lovely days by lithuanian
seashore so the answer is obvious so
we've we've basically stopped all
visions to people who would go for
recreation
and the only visas that are issued is
the humanitarian cause visas
so for us this is not a new debate and
obviously we support that it would be a
european decision uh because as you know
when schengen
works like that that basically is a
porous uh borders that means that people
are entering one country
finland issues a visa to someone then
this somewhere anywhere exactly and
we've seen those cases as well
people who are not supposed to be in
lithia they are suddenly finding
themselves in in lithuania or in other
countries so it happens
uh so we would totally support the
european decision and then yes obviously
there is a political side of the
question you know the moral question you
know when we understand that you know
the people uh were forced to flee uh
ukraine uh some of them are remaining
there fighting for their lives fighting
there for for their homes uh while you
know the country who is at war is is
still free to uh you know people from
the country still free to to travel and
enjoy all the amendments of the free
world basically which uh their
government is is fighting against
but
the russian opposition
at least
part of it is saying that
uh
these visa bans prevent people from
traveling to the eu and to safety
prevent those ngo activists those
political activists
that are threatened by
long jail sentences in russia now so
what they're saying is essentially you
are playing
putin's cars you're playing putin's
hands yeah well i i would not say that
and you know
answering the first question was that uh
lithuania has
i think it is an excellent example and
we managed to combine stopping tourist
visas and stopping you know people who
would come here for pleasure and
actually allowing people who are
uh running away from from persecution
and and then again i mean it's you know
we have to answer ourselves a broader
question
what kind of russia do we manage in the
future is it the russia who is uh like
you know having two russians so to say
that one that is dictatorial
uh the people who
decided to stay there remain there they
do not care and everybody else who is
against the war who's you know have the
democrat democratic spirit they left
kind of this you know it's already a
reality these two russia's already a
reality not necessarily i would not say
that you know when when we say that you
know even if if it were five ten percent
of people in russia uh who are against
the war we're talking millions of people
so do you want those millions inside of
russia or outside of russia what's your
answer
i would i would still believe that
the change comes from within
and if we if we believe that
there is a democratic russia in the
future it will come from within
and from basically from those from those
you know five seven 15 you know who
knows how many how many percentage but
this this comes from from there
to wrap up the visa issue so
if and when
let us say the eu the commission the the
european council sits down to decide
on the unified
visa policy what will be lithuanian's
final position
i would i would suggest that lithium's
path is is the one that could be
followed that basically we we stopped
the visa issuance
uh for people who are coming here for
any means other than uh humanitarian
and and how do you assess humanitarian
we found a way working with
non-governmental organizations working
with
many other
partners uh where we are able to assess
actually you know who who has a
humanitarian need who's running away
from persecution and who's basically
would like to to pretend and just you
know have a
more simple life here in
in lithuania or in the west well talking
about lithuania generally
does it feel threatened by russia
frankly do you feel that there could be
a major russian
infiltration that will destabilize
lithuania i'm not talking about invasion
even now you're talking about the people
who would come here yeah no no not at
this point i think that uh even though
we hear a lot more russian speakers in
in the street in the cafes restaurants
whatever
uh because as you know you know there
are so many ukrainians who arrived
there's so many belarusians arrived and
so many russians who arrived so
you feel the change but whether it's uh
whether we feel threatened or no
i think that the the checks and balances
procedure that we have currently it is
uh it's working
and uh we're able to trust the system so
to say that it's it's it works in both
advantage of lithuania and also in those
people who are seeking shelter
miss lansberges
together with other baltic states was
from the beginning this is quite a long
time actually
among ukraine staunchest supporters
especially since the 24th of february
when ukraine faced off a new round of
putin's aggression
what's your assessment of the situation
now
well the state of the conflict i mean uh
i think that we've been
uh not just political supporters but
what what what the government of
lithuania was saying since the very
first days of the conflict that the
conflict will be decided in the
battlefield
the history shows it that common sense
shows it and explains it that basically
the country has to have means to defend
itself and to fight off the aggression
and it was a very tough debate
honestly i mean first months it was you
know whether ukrainians will be able to
use the weaponry will will will it not
fall into uh invaders hands and i mean
it was it was a very difficult debate
and still ongoing actually
but seeing what ukrainians managed to do
with the equipment that they got
this is actually proving the point
that if that equipment was delivered to
ukraine earlier we might not have seen
what we've seen already
uh ukrainians are able to fight off
to stop fight off and even reclaim the
land that that was occupied after after
the 24th so
i i truly
believe and i hope
that this is proof enough
that unions are capable able and
trustworthy partners when it comes to
defending the the borders of
of europe so to save from there from the
invasion
and uh the only the only thing that
remains to be to be said is you know
provide more weapons provide more
weapons so the more weapons are provided
the faster the warrants we'll come back
to the state of affairs now
in a second but since you mentioned
weapons
germany has been criticized frequently
including by the government of lithuania
other central european states
some people in the u.s for
kind of not doing enough to supply
weapons to
uh to ukraine uh
are you satisfied with what berlin is
doing now how it's helping here i'm i'm
not you know in in in the position to
criticize our partners and allies i mean
i would believe that everybody is doing
what they are able to do
due to political reasons
industrial reasons whatever i mean you
know i know that lithuanian government
was doing our part and our share to the
best of our ability and this is you know
this is what i can
uh i can tell you now the question
remains is um
because yesterday it was announced that
the united states is providing
additional tranche of weaponry for again
one more billion billion dollars
and when you you know when you see the
scope of the equipment that was provided
by the united states and you compare
that to what was provided to europe
uh you might see that
the
uh
the times when united states was a major
weapon provided to european continent
after the second world war or even
during the second world war are not so
uh we believe that they are over
that europe especially with the notions
of strategic autonomy you know that it's
a industrial powerhouse that it's able
to produce a job at the french
no but it's it's a serious discussion
it's a serious discussion
but now
i think that we have to rethink you know
we clearly see what is lacking
we clearly see what is lacking so that
europe could step up
and start defending our own continent
with at least comparable
measures that are being provided by by
the us because now we're seeing that
here u.s is picking pace you know
sending more and more weaponry which is
being used so effectively in in the
ukraine and i you know i feel this
i would like to feel more european pride
so to say seeing more european weaponry
that is that is provided to ukraine
alongside american but unfortunately
probably we still don't have the
capacity what is something to think
about
not in the far future but i would i
would suggest we start thinking about
this now but you know in this city in
vilnius and a few other uh central
european capitals european capital is
even wider speaking
this kind of conversation about europe
doing more always
provokes
a bit of a
sort of
risky feeling that it could somehow
undermine nato if you start speaking
about european strategic autonomy
obviously you know it is impossible to
undermine undermine nato and then and
start speaking in the sense whether it
is possible to change nato or change a
transatlantic union with something else
obviously it's not doable and especially
for the reasons because it's so obvious
in in ukraine you know who's carrying
the
the biggest weight well unfortunately
it's not the european continent at this
at this point you know we can do a lot
of things when it comes to humanitarian
aid you know we're doing so much and
germany is doing so much when it comes
to uh refugees you know there are
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians
currently in
in germany
uh but regards to you know hard power
actually fighting off the invasion well
it's still the transatlantic union
but then again i think that coming
further to the 21st century you know
which i will i would
expect that it's not the last
geopolitical turmoil that we will see in
in the 21st century future stability
will be maintained with a transatlantic
unity it will be based on the
transatlantic unity so i would i would
expect europe to play a stronger role in
this also from the military standpoint
since you mentioned transatlantic union
unity and transatlantic relationship
uh
it seems that
in the midterms elections in the us and
then probably 2024 presidential election
uh will see a rise in kind of
isolationist feeling in the u.s
associated uh with but not exclusively
uh donald trump and his team um are you
afraid for the future of the
transatlantic relationship
well i think that
this this year showed how important
transatlantic unity is
for the both sides of atlantic
and you know the discussion was
again even even during the last
administration it was happening on the
both sides you know uh
nobody needs to be reminded that
the discussion about strategic autonomy
happened
when donald trump was running the white
house in in washington
um
but
now
it is obvious that both sides need each
other you know in order to maintain
their
their security infrastructure or
architecture of of this part of the of
the globe but also globally
so i would hope that everybody starts
seeing this and i had many conversations
in in washington during my
my my few years in in the position uh
where you know i tried to to speak and
meet people from both sides of the aisle
and
you know this is probably one of the
main questions that you know the people
politicians coming from the baltics
would ask you know would you maintain
the course and i got so many responses
that the cost will be maintained
so even though
you know it is it's choppy times and uh
things might happen but i still hope
that we all see what provides us secure
accessibility
uh some time ago you said that in your
view the european union is not doing
enough to deter putin's aggression
does it now
in your view
well i would say that
ukrainians with with their rocket
launchers are doing
the most
heavy heavy lifting in order to deter
further further
putin's invasion obviously because you
know he was he was speaking about three
days to take care of you know uh he had
plans to obviously had plans you know to
go even further than that and i i would
believe that those plans are somewhere
around his table
but
he's nowhere near kiev
he's not even you know he cannot even
cover the whole eastern eastern front
you know he's now uh trying to defend
her son
and uh so
i would say that
this is basically it's it's still very
it's quite simple actually
you know weapons incapable hands will to
fight is the biggest deterrence
okay i understood you but what
should be done
uh by the european union can the
european union do more apart from i
understood their position regarding
weapon supplies
what can the eu do
i think that was it's it's high time we
start thinking about the post-war
situation uh
from from from many perspectives so
first of all geopolitical you know it's
it's becoming a holiday cliche you know
your political union but i still think
it's it's an important notion that we
have not we need not to let out of our
side
that means that
uh
one step was taken your political step
which is very important you know
granting the candidate stages for
ukraine and and moldova
i think this is a step in the very right
direction but then we have to assist
with uh with the transition
not just recovery from the war but
actually transitioning helping countries
transition to
to full
full membership you know be it you know
years in the future who knows but
actually europe has to be very active in
this and then to formulate a very clear
strategy on on russia but even going
beyond that because europe's strategy on
russia is also
a signal to other possible
um
invaders so to say or disruptors of the
of the global security order how
democracies democratic unions and
especially geopolitical unions like
european union would react in case of
progression
what is what is you know do we see in
china let's let's face it i mean but
disruption happens in in smaller cases
as well you know we're seeing uh
many these uh sparks happening you know
globally
and
i think
there is a belief a certain belief among
the many especially less democratic
actors who would say that okay there are
so many balls in the air you know where
europe and united states cannot juggle
all the balls so if we throw one more of
them maybe they lose all of it and maybe
the situation is written so that we can
benefit from it
and we're seeing you know new new
conflicts or possible
areas of conflict happening why in
kosovo and serbia or i mean in
azerbaijan i think you you kind of
you know why it is now
why now you see all these flares
basically just throw
throw a new new issue new ball and
expect that it will be just too much to
handle so europe european union has to
be prepared for that um what about
coming back to
russia's war against ukraine what about
the sanctions does european union have
more sanctions kind of in its arsenal
if yes then what do you think
i think that
the the appetite for sanctions for
additional sanctions is is used up
uh i think that many european countries
are looking uh worryingly at uh the
coming winter
when it comes to
gas prices and all that
uh but i think that this
this will not be as bad as as expected
it's always better to expect the worst
and kind of and be
prepared uh prepared for the for the
situation that might not be so good and
then kind of have the instruments to uh
um to tackle the the upcoming problems
but
i think that
basically it will not be as bad and i
would hope that we will be able to
return
to increasing pressure on on russia when
we see that we are able that europe is
able to handle the situation when it
comes to energy and other things aren't
you afraid that this energy looming
energy crisis will lead to more calls
for quote-unquote peace you mentioned
that in your view
this uh war the outcome of this conflict
will be decided
but there are lots of people
in other european capitals very big ones
that think that eventually you have to
talk peace
do you think that this will be in your
proposition
because of the energy crisis in winter
oh let's engage putin
well we'll see you know one of the the
things that differs us us from uh from
these these days in russia is democracy
that we have
in in europe that means that you know
the government's changed new power new
parties arrive and they start they might
see the situation changing i would
believe that the current picture of the
european continent and in 27 european
countries is
is quite a stable one even though the
opinions do differ
i don't see any major
change
in uh in political sense when it comes
to the processes in in russia that means
that answering your question you know
would any current government would ask
strongly you know for you know for peace
with russia i don't believe that uh but
having said that you know governments do
change
do change and you know some
as i mentioned new new parties or old
new parties that are returning would
come and they might have some some
proposals so to say that they could put
on the table
but you're against them you're against
talking to putin in general uh
absolutely i mean
you know when when countries acknowledge
what is being happened and we
acknowledge that this hasn't happened
without the political consent or
actually with a with endorsement and
with there may be encouragement even of
the of the political elite in in moscow
i don't believe you know how is it
possible to uh to to
have any normality
since we talked about sanctions uh
must they hurt
the russian population at large
well they will hurt russian population
unfortunately that's that's that's how
it works russian population in itself
and especially you know we started our
discussion about about the visa bans
uh tourist visa events
so yes unfortunately russian population
will
uh will be forced to you know to limit
their vacations to to limit their the
things that they can they can purchase
and always i think that the
there there was middle class i believe
especially in the big cities in in
russia i was forming that was used to
that what could be called the western
way of life and i think this
this this is over it's a very small
segment of the russian population well i
would not believe that it's very small
especially in moscow
yes but on the other hand there's an
argument that if you pressure and this
argument is not exclusively applicable
to this situation that
they debated it every time sanctions
were imposed against some country
that once you impose very tough
sanctions the population tends to really
round the regime really around the
leader in this case really around putin
are you afraid of that i think that you
know where in many cases we're seeing
that
that already happening right i mean it's
difficult to trust the polls that uh you
know that we see you know who knows what
people are answering who knows you know
what what the what question that the
poster asked so it's it's difficult to
believe those those those polls but
basically i think that we see some
tendencies we see that you know there is
a trust in a strong leader that's always
been there you know especially after the
um
certain
uh expeditions uh by by russians groups
in 2008 2014 we always see a hike in in
trust in in putin so i would not be so
much surprised that we're
seeing something similar similar right
now but then again
uh going back you know to um to the
beginning
russia is a big country so having you
know beat again ten percent of the
population
are deeply against that's a lot of
people that's a lot of people
the issue is whether they can express
their feelings yes uh
probably now it is very difficult for
them but i believe that time will come
um
just recently actually this summer
the eu
overturned at least part of its policy
regarding transit from mainland russia
to the russian territory exclave of
kaliningrad uh on the baltic sea
lithuania wanted basically to block old
transit from russia to
uh to kalingrad the eu said no part of
it is
kind of
we can't allow it
uh do you feel it's a sign of weakness
do you feel lithuania was to a large
extent betrayed by brussels no i believe
that first of all lithuania wanted that
brussels maintains its original stance
we believe that it was fair
uh we believe that russia has means to
uh to bring goods to kaliningrad you
know
so it should not be a
in any case a european issue
it's a it's a russian issue it's not a
european issue
in any case um after
long deliberations uh the decision was
uh amended
and as it currently stands there is a
quota system
where europe has set limits to how much
of
what is called essential goods
coal
timber
is needed in in canadian and that
amounts these amounts can be transferred
through the european territory
um
so it is um
in from my perspective it's not ideal
it is a certain
compromise that that we accepted
and
it can be worked
it can be worked with
the kremlin exploded with rage when
lithuania tried to block this transit
and
this rage to the logic extent continues
if you look at russian television
do you feel that putin has designs on
lithuanian sovereignty ukraine
lithuanian territory
do you trust that nato will defend him
well um
first of all
russian propaganda tried to portray this
as a something that lithium did
and uh we've
you know we
it's difficult to explain it
to russian propaganda
but i might use this opportunity to
explain too you know to the people who
are watching our conversation is that it
was a european decision
literally implemented a european
decision
so maybe russia was should have been
should have been not happy with the
european decision but it's always to be
to pick a fight for that you know much
smaller uh much smaller country like
like lithuania you know this is how this
is what bullies usually do
we are not afraid of russia we believe
that nato is um is that strongest and
most capable alliance there is and there
was ever was
we're very delighted to read um
announcements that our neighbors from
from estonia are purchasing uh 500
million euros worth of high mars rockets
next year
hopefully we'll uh will follow their
steps and i think this is also
certain certain things that how
how basically we see what needs to what
needs to happen in in our region and we
will we will arm ourselves
we will continue doing that and it it
should send a message that this is
this is not
a territory where
uh
russian russian troops on the order of
putin can and have a expedition
this is
a war that we see which
the continent didn't witness
for the last eight years nearly
how do you think will it last
i know that you said it depends on the
ukrainians but it also depends on a lot
of factors
your gut feeling if you wish how long
uh europe should be prepared to live
with this war well i
it's difficult to to answer this
question specifically i mean
when it comes to you know war strategies
and all that
basically i can tell you that it is my
very strong belief that the west have
all the means to help ukrainians finish
this war very fast
mr lansberges thank you very much thank
you so much
you